des cirques est un bagne pour les
animaux cette archive date de 1978
on prétend que les animaux ils sont
heureux c'est absolument font ils sont
condamnés aux travaux forcés à
perpétuité et à la captivité
cette militante batailler pour faire
interdire la présence d'animaux sauvages
dans les cirques
tout comme les associations de défense
des animaux aujourd'hui cette prise de
conscience a donc débuté dans les années
70 les spectateurs en auront pour leur
argent
les spectateurs pas tous certains
d'entre eux une minorité refuse
aujourd'hui d'admettre que l'animal
puisse subir la captivité pour servir de
support au spectacle les militants
dénoncent et la captivité les mauvais
traitements le dressage violent les
mauvaises conditions de vie des animaux
sauvages dans les cirques une
porte-parole emblématique à l'époque
brigitte bardot elle n'hésitait pas à
interpeller andré jarrot alors ministre
de la qualité de vie monsieur le
ministre je vous rappelle que avec les
eaux il faut penser aux ménagerie de
cirque parce que le problème est
exactement le même
et les animaux qui sont dans des cages
et que l'on trimballe dans toute la
france qui sont toutes petites cages
comme ça en même sort que les animaux
des eaux alors je compte sur vous pouvez
penser beaucoup penser aux ménages
de la maltraitance dont se défend dé la
famille bouglione qui était poussé à
réagir aux accusations des militants
j'en pense pas grand chose parce que
c'est pas vrai des pubs à la répétition
si je pense que si on maltraite les
animaux rien n'arrive à leur faire faire
cours ou contre les animaux sauvages
dans les cirques
déjà dans les années 70 les journalistes
prenait en exemple les pays du nord les
numéros avec des animaux sauvages y
était interdit
pour l'avenir le chiffre peu à peu sera
transformé je pense parce que les gens
de cirque seront obligés de se plier à
la volonté du public lequel que big
cherche aujourd'hui à respecter l'animal
selon un sondage commandé par 30
millions d'amis 67% des français sont
favorables à l'interdiction des animaux
sauvages dans les cirques autres indices
de changements de mentalité de plus en
plus d'élus locaux refusent d'accueillir
des cirques ayant des numéros avec des
animaux sauvages et même certains
circassiens ont banni de leur spectacle
lions et autres éléphants
[Musique]